uh when you first started
you know out
boom you be we talked about that i met
you when you're like 50 000 instagram
followers now you're at 6 million
you caught fire very quick and you got
the attention of
people like diddy
and you started doing some stuff with
diddy p diddy exactly love
explain your relationship with diddy
what he's done for you and what he's
helped you know build your brand and
brand deal yeah
man i love the combs family they
literally are
like
extended family they've given me life
they've given me love they've brought me
in as their own they supported my dreams
my goals before they even knew me you
know so it was big to
meet someone like p diddy and let alone
his family you know his kids are like my
brothers you know his family is my
family you know he's just he's a great
role model to have someone to talk to a
great figure in life you know some
people know him from the outside but
when you're on the inside and you see
him actually work i mean it's just
amazing and actually be a dad and be a
mentor and be a business owner you know
it's just
it's cool to see
that level of
expertise flow out of someone so
effortless with passion and you know
still have time for someone on the
outside you know they don't know me a
couple years ago but soon as we got to
hang out and meet
just
off the rip you know what what com like
everyone knows diddy
um i believe we have a video right here
yeah but my question on the other side
of this is you can't play the video but
we can just show them okay gotcha we
can't play the video all right we don't
want to get taken down but anyway that's
you with what diddy's kids yeah did he
went on jimmy kimmel yeah okay like
gave mad love you know can you show the
next frame or you can't you even show
the video anyway that yeah there it is
diddy's okay sick
right the man himself and he's on jimmy
kimmel on freaking abc talking about you
yeah man how does that make you feel
knowing that he can talk about anything
he's talking about you just i mean
imagine being a kid listening to biggie
smalls and diddy you know and then like
one day he's on jimmy kimmel giving you
a thumbs up giving you the blessing take
that take that what you know
the you know i'm a bad boy for life you
have to be at this point like literally
what do you think
everyone knows diddy everyone knows his
songs everyone know you know the famous
scene of him like
throwing down the phone he's like give
me something i got this or whatever i
i'll do whatever i want everything like
that if people know diddy like that
what is the one thing that people don't
know about diddy that you've learned bro
he's like he's love nothing but love
pure energy you know i think he changed
his name to love and that's all it is
man is like people see on the outside
again a business mogul someone that's
completely motivated someone that's
scary you know but
guys love man he's just straight up love
everybody that works for him works with
him everybody's around him love him and
he loves them back wow you know and it's
so cool to see that you know from
his personal assistants to his kids to
people on out i mean
everybody loves diddy you know because
he literally is a walking
energy of love
you know you've uh you've also been
fortunate enough to meet some major
celebs will smith who comes to mind of
like holy [ __ ] i can't believe i'm
meeting these people mike tyson yeah
like i have mike tyson tattoo on my
finger
iron mike can we scroll in on this iron
mike put that out there
so yeah it gives you an idea of how much
i love someone like tyson well pat pbd
just interviewed tyson in vegas i was
there this was i don't know a few months
ago and the the one story that i'll
never forget about tyson
is he said um
pat asked him when did you know
that you were going to be a world
champion he said i was 14 years old
and he was 14. he's like who are you
even fighting at that point he goes no
in order to
uh in order to become the champion you
must be the champion and it was all
about his championship mindset
and then he tells the story about how he
was fist fighting kids at yeah i mean
i'm sure we could play this he was fist
fighting kids at 12 years old beat the
[ __ ] out of the kids and the father
shows up and he starts beating the kids
father's ass like that's mike tyson
that's how you you know tattooed on your
on your fingers right there so you've
met tyson what did tyson mean for you i
mean it's like
put an adult male lion in here and lock
the vault right that's what it feels
like being next to mike tyson straight
up you know it's like in a good way in a
good way okay you know because he's he's
being nice to you you know it's iron
mike yeah the most ferocious fish like
let me tell you so right i was there we
were backstage because i was with pat we
were putting this whole event together
shout out to mike tyson in pbd and
backstage i was talking with them and i
was like yo mike can we get a picture
and we we were sitting there just like
that and i go yeah can you can you give
me one of these like while we're he's
like man i i ain't trying to fight you
man when you put your fist down baby
like shake my hand i was like whatever
you say mike but like he could have did
this but no he was just like nah man i
just peace and love did smell like weed
though
respect i don't know he could have
passed me the joint that's fine but you
didn't want to share that okay anyone
else come to mind that you're like holy
[ __ ] will smith mike tyson who else
comes to mind that you've met
let me see this guy named robbie brettel
he's a
barefoot bushman out in australia he's
like one of the og steve irwins before
siberia robbie brittle robert do you
spell the name uh b-r-e-d-l you guys
david's on the ball he's on it i mean
like robbie brettel is
if there's a tarzan or
something out there it's that guy that's
that guy yeah robbie's from australia
okay he's uh i think i'm right in the
number but i think he spent
15 years
outside
15 years outside like not living out
this house not homeless not homeless
living just living outside all right
david i don't know if you can find this
guy right no shoes
you've met obviously some crazy
celebrities you're tight with diddy you
got mike tyson you know you did hot
boxing with uh with tyson um
what's the biggest lesson you've learned
from internet fame this is robbie hold
that first photo
oh it's insanity like look at that
so
wow that's insane
um
so back to the question
you